bonsoir m'écoutais je suis ravi d'être
ici ce soir parmi vous pour vous
partager une vision un projet de société
depuis que j'ai 20 ans j'essaie de
trouver des solutions pour changer le
monde avec toute mon énergie et mes
convictions et en fait à force de
chercher j'ai réalisé qu'on avait un
partenaire de choix à nos côtés un
partenaire qu'on avait tendance
un petit peu a oublié voire à malmener
c'est pas n'importe quel partenaire
c'est un laboratoire un laboratoire
incroyable qui a trois milliards
d'années d'expérience ces deux
laboratoires du vivant la nature a
réussi à développer des technologies
incroyable pour relever tous les défis
auxquels elle avait été confrontée des
technologies sobres en énergie
parce qu'elle ne fonctionne qu'avec
l'énergie du soleil des technologies
résiliente qui savent donc s'adapter des
technologies qui produisent pas de
déchets bien aux 10 10 est l'architecte
du futur construira en imitant la nature
parce que c'est la plus rationnelle
durable et économique des méthodes et il
avait raison
c'est en observant les libellules qu'on
a réussi à faire voler un hélicoptère
les ingénieurs japonais pourtant
brillant ont fini par faire un simple
copier coller du nez du martin pêcheur
pour dessiner leur tgv s'inspirer de la
nature
ça s'appelle le biomimétisme alors il ya
une américaine janine benyus une
précurseur en la matière qui a écrit un
livre incroyable sur le sujet un livre
passionnant c'est un gros pavé de 600
pages dans lequel elle référence toutes
les solutions propres et circulaires
qu'on pourrait adapter de la nature à
nos enjeux de société en matière
d'énergie de transport de santé de
gestion de l'entreprise et
d'alimentation elle consacre le premier
livre le premier chapitre de son livre à
l'agriculture et elle conclut c'est
soixante dix premières pages en disant
que si nous sommes réellement
sincèrement convaincu qu'il faut créer
un nouveau monde pour le bien des
générations futures
alors la première brique le socle sur
lequel on doit ériger ce nouveau
paradigme
c'est l'agriculture du coup je me suis
beaucoup intéressée au sujet et j'ai
compris pas mal de choses notamment
comment l'histoire de l'alimentation et
de l'agriculture avait été remodelée
dans un contexte de pétrole pas cher en
minant 50 ans on a / 25 notre efficacité
énergétique pour produire de
l'agriculture pour produire de
l'alimentation en 1940 avec une calorie
fossiles on arrivait à produire deux
points 4 calories alimentaires
aujourd'hui il nous faut 7 à 10 calories
fossiles pour produire une calorie
alimentaire c'est incroyable la quoi
c'est dû mais c'est dû à nos méthodes de
production à coups de tracteurs qui
brûlent 25 litres de gazole par heure
c'est du l'épandage massif de produits
pétrochimiques
c'est dû aux emballages ceci dû au fait
quand vous mangez un plat cuisiné à kiel
après parcouru 1500 km avant d'arriver
dans votre assiette
heureusement en a marre en matière
d'alimentation et d'agriculture
la nature a beaucoup à nous apprendre
une forêt par exemple produit 600 fois
plus de matières 600 fois plus de
biomasse cash en anglais alors
s'inspirer de la nature pour faire de
l'agriculture ça s'appelle de la
permaculture
ça vient de cultures permanentes en fait
si on veut être rigoureux la
permaculture c'est l'art et la
philosophie de concevoir des écosystèmes
humains équilibré c'est donc pas à
proprement parler une méthode agricole
on peut faire de la permaculture en
gérant son entreprise gérant sa famille
qui doivent être des écosystèmes sains
et équilibrés
on peut faire de la permaculture en
construisant un bâtiment à énergie
positive ou bien en produisant des
objets à partir de déchets grâce par
exemple à des imprimantes 3d
donc qu'est ce qu'elle nous apprend la
nature qu'est ce qu'elle nous apprend la
nature elle nous apprend pas mal de
choses le premier enseignement qu'on
peut prendre de la nature sait que la
terre ne doit jamais être à nu vous ne
verrez jamais dans la nature un bout de
terre sans rien dessus dès qu'un rayon
de soleil arrive sur le sol une plante
se développe
fait de la photosynthèse et se développe
et c'est tant mieux c'est important les
plantes à ce que c'est grâce aux plantes
qu'il ya de la vie dans le seul
vous imaginez bien que dans tout les
plaines céréalières de la beauce qui
restent à nu pendant une grande partie
de l'hiver les vers de terre n'ont plus
rien à manger les décomposeurs n'ont
plus rien à décomposer et puis quand ya
pas de plantes ya pas de racines non
plus donc quand il pleut y'a plus rien
pour retenir la terre elle serra do sol
se déstructurer en faire des tonnes du
musée des tonnes de fertilité
chaque année d'ailleurs vous le voyez
bien dans les rivières à la fin de
l'hiver toute la terre charrier qui sort
de nos champs alors pour éviter ça en
permaculture qu'est ce qu'on fait et
bien on paye en couvrent le sol avec de
la paille comme je dis ou avec de la
tonte de gazon du brf du bois raméal
fragmenté
on peut aussi faire des engrais verts
donc des engrais verts sont des plantes
qu'on met entre deux cultures dans une
rotation et ses engrais verts il fixe de
l'azoté dans le sol il fertilise donc et
c'est ça qui est génial dans la
permaculture c'est que une action peut
avoir plusieurs incidence plusieurs
fonctions quand on met de la paille sur
le sol sacré de la matière organique
ça entretient la vie dans ceux du sol
mais ça permet aussi d'éviter la pousse
des adventices des mauvaises herbes
parce que ça opacifie le sol et donc du
coup on économise beaucoup en désherbage
mais la paille ça permet aussi
d'économiser de l'eau puisque en fait
c'est la limite l'évapotranspiration de
la terre et donc sa garde une fraîcheur
une vraie humilité
voilà le type d'idées qu'on peut avoir
grâce à la nature pour cultiver un autre
enseignement de la nature qui est très
important c'est la culture de la
diversité c'est impossible de savoir
combien il y à des espèces vivant dans
100 mètres carrés de forêt tellement il
y en a et c'est ça c'est justement la
clé de la productivité c'est la
diversité en retard la culture on essaie
de faire pareil du coup on essaye
d'avoir le plus d'espèces en présence
ont fait des associations de culture on
plante des arbres on essaie de se
rapprocher de la forêt comestibles on
essaye d'être accueillants pour les
aides pour les insectes pour les animaux
pour lutter contre les pucerons et ben
on
on fait confiance aux coccinelles et
puis pour se prémunir des limaces et
bien aux comptes sur les hérissons ou
les grenouilles
si jamais on lutter de manière chimiques
contre les pucerons
mais les larves de coccinelles elle
n'aurait plus rien à manger et du coup
elles reviendraient plus dans notre
ferme et l'année suivante on serait
obligés d'utiliser des pesticides
donc voilà donc c'est ce genre d'idées
qu'il faut absolument prendre de la
nature pour cultiver différemment quand
je me suis intéressé à ça en 2010 j'ai
découvert la ferme du bec hellouin c'est
une forme absolument incroyable en
normandie
c'est totalement inspirée de la
permaculture c'est une ferme luxuriante
un espèce de jardin d'éden elle est
tellement productive qu'elle fait
l'objet d'une étude de l'inra qui prouve
que sur 1000 mètres carrés planté il
arrive à produire 50 mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait l'année dernière c'est pas du tout
c'est énorme 50000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires sur 1000 mètres carrés c'est
dix fois plus que dans l'agriculture
conventionnelle et c'est pas la seule
femme qui fonctionne comme ça il ya
beaucoup de servir une forme
impressionnante au québec qui s'appelle
la ferme de la grelinette et qui fait
beaucoup d'émules
du coup quand j'étais convaincu et de la
pertinence et de la puissance du projet
je suis allé voir le directeur de
recherche de l'inra qui mène cette étude
de bec hellouin et je vais demander
comment est-ce qu'on pouvait aider à
dupliquer ce type de fermes sur le
territoire lui m'a dit que ce qui était
intéressant pour lui en tant que
chercheur c'était évidemment de pouvoir
suivre une ferme en rythme de croisière
comme celle du bec hellouin qui donne de
vrais espoirs en termes de production
saine et intensive mais que ce qui était
intéressant pour lui aussi c'était de
pouvoir suivre une ferme en phase
d'installation
parce que c'est une période un peu
compliquée c'est derrière cette période
qui sert d'alibi à beaucoup de syndicats
beaucoup de lobby agricole pour ne rien
changer aux modèles en place et ce
modèle en place il est complètement à
bout de souffle
en cinquante ans on a perdu un million
et demi de ferme en france
dans le même temps on est passé de 10 %
d'agriculteurs à 2% agriculteurs on a
perdu entre un tiers et la moitié de
toute la matière organique de nos sols
et ça on n'a aucune formule magique pour
le récupérer
le modèle de demain il devra
nécessairement polluer moins consommer
moins de ressources et employé plus de
gens et ça pour employer plus de gens il
va falloir nécessairement des gens de la
ville accepte de retourner habiter à la
campagne
pour recréer pourquoi pas des
écosystèmes humains équilibrée dans les
villages abandonnés de france part ça je
me voyais bien le dire moi depuis depuis
mon petit univers parisien mais j'avais
jamais planté une tomate
j'ai été pas sûr d'être complètement
crédible et du coup j'ai décidé puisque
l' aventure me tentait aussi de moi même
me lancer dans l'expérience
à l'époque je dirigeais une maison
d'édition je faisais des planches
pédagogiques sur le développement
durable
je travaille avec louis albert de braye
que vous connaissez peut-être sous le
surnom de prince jardinier il a créé le
conservatoire national de la tomate à
quelques kilomètres d'ici
avec 650 variété de m on a décidé
ensemble que cette ferme expérimentale
on la fraîche et lui sur un hectare 4
donc je suis parti je me suis formée en
maraîchage biologique
j'ai été visité beaucoup de fermes on a
monté une équipe et puis on a créé
l'association ferme d'avenir et on s'est
dit on a défini un pari et des objectifs
le parie d'abord le pari c'est prouvé
scientifiquement que l'agro écologie
peut être plus rentable que
l'agriculture conventionnelle ça on en
est sûr on va essayer de le faire et on
sait ce qu'on est en train de faire sur
cette ferme notre ferme sur nectar 4 il
va coûter moins cher qu'un tracteur
elle consommera pas de pétrole si tout
marche bien à l'année 4 on sera à
l'équilibré économique et on aura créé
trois emplois sur 1 hectare 4 à titre de
comparaison trois emplois en alliant
maraîchage conventionnelle c'est plutôt
sur 9 hectares
donc on peut employer 6 fois plus de
monde grâce à ce type d'agriculture nos
objectifs maintenant le premier objectif
c'est de donner aux chercheurs de l'inra
tous les chiffres dont ils ont besoin
pour évaluer le modèle économique donc
on note tout à la ferme on note le temps
de travail le coup
l'évolution de la productivité et ils
font rentrer il rentrer ça dans leur
moulinette et un médecin en miroir du
modèle traditionnel
le deuxième objectif c'est de créer une
boîte à outils qui permettraient à toute
personne qui le souhaite de reproduire
cette expérience de reproduire ce type
de ferme parce qu'en fait c'est vrai
c'est ça une vraie révolution de la
chose de du projet en tout cas une vraie
révolution que peut apporter la
permaculture c'est de dire qu' on n'a
plus besoin de 50 ou 100 hectares pour
s'installer devenir agriculteur on peut
le faire d un ou deux hectares et ça ça
change tout parce qu'un hectare aux 2 ha
ça se trouve partout il ya beaucoup de
propriétaires fonciers que ce soit des
particules
et des entreprises des collectivités
locales qui serait donc prêt à mettre un
ou deux hectares à disposition par
exemple pour fournir la cantine de
l'école
le troisième objectif c'est pas le plus
simple c'est évaluer les services
écosystémiques rendus par ce type
d'agriculture
en gros on dit qu'un agriculteur il
n'est pas là juste pour produire de la
nourriture un agriculteur il préserve la
biodiversité il entretient la qualité de
l'eau y cultive la santé des gens quand
il fait des bons produits il ses caisses
du carbone ils façonnent les paysages et
créer des dynamiques sur le territoire
c'est super compliqué d'évaluer ce que
ça représente
imaginez de system un système où on n'a
des vers de terre qui créé gratuitement
de la fertilité et un autre système où
on a plus de vers de terre nous faire
cette fertilité artificiellement
combien de sous il faut pour égaler
l'efficacité des vers de terre dans la
même veine vous savez sans doute qu'en
ce moment on vit une grosse extase
extinction des abeilles en chine en ce
moment ils sont en train de payer des
gars qui vont fertiliser qui vont
polliniser à la main des pommiers dans
les vergers
c'est complètement absurde
donc pour évaluer tout ça avec la avec
l'association on a créé un comité
scientifique qui évalue les impacts
positifs et qui essaie de chiffrer
et si on y arrive on pourra convaincre
les politiques qu'il est bien plus
intelligent de financer maintenant ce
type d'agriculture plutôt que de payer
dans quelques années des fortunes pour
réparer les dégâts
et d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas besoin
d'attendre nos chiffres pour commencer
les perturbateurs endocriniens ça vous
parle sans doute ça coûte 80 milliards
par an à la france
c'est juste du aux pesticides on dit
qu'on n'a pas les sous pour arrêter les
pesticides mais en fait si on arrête les
pesticides on économise 80 milliards
donc on peut financer ça dès maintenant
vous comprenez on essaie de donner une
dimension sociétale voire politique même
un qui peut à notre projet et donc on
essaie de l'inscrire dans une réalité
économiques parce que c'est la seule
c'est la seule condition à laquelle on
va pouvoir le répandre et le dupliquer
sur les territoires et donc quand on dit
ça il ya un chiffre qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est que 70 % des fruits et
légumes en france sont vendus en grande
surface ou en hard discount et donc dès
le départ on a voulu à
haussier dans cette démarche la grande
distribution parce qu'on pourra pas
changer le modèle agricole
s'ils ne viennent pas avec nous donc on
est allé les voir et chose surprenante
ils nous ont bien accueillis
enfin surprenant s'est pas complètement
surprenant parce que quand on est allé
les voir c'était la crise des lasagnes
la viande de cheval
donc du coup ils essayaient ils étaient
en train d'essayer de trouver des
solutions pour reconquérir leur public
pour pour travailler sur la traçabilité
de leurs fournisseurs
donc c'était peut-être un peu de la com
mais pas que parce qu'en fait
économiquement c'est très rentable pour
eux c'est très c'est logique
aujourd'hui ils achètent des tomates qui
viennent d'espagne ils savent très bien
que quand le baril de pétrole jour à 300
ou 500 dollars les tomates espagnoles
seront plus du tout compétitive avec des
tomates local même bio donc voilà donc
très concrètement on a lancé cette ferme
il ya un an et demi on tient nos
objectifs on est très satisfait de voir
que la nature est généreuse
quand on prend soin d'elle nous le rend
bien moi j'ai découvert un métier je
suis devenu maraîchers les mis les mains
dans la terre ça métier passionnant on
fait beaucoup de choses on est au grand
air moi j'ai perdu cinq kilos je suis
bronzé toute l'année et je suis assez
content après faut pas idéaliser non
plus le métier d'agriculteur il ya pas
mal de choses qu'il faut encore inventé
métier d'agriculteur est quand même
compliquée il faut être assidu il faut
être bon techniquement il faut être
assidu il faut gérer ses factures il
faut avoir la pêche tout le temps il
faut bien vendre bien acheter enfin
c'est quand même un métier très complet
très complexe ça va être un petit peu un
superman et si jamais on veut créer 200
ou 500 mille emplois dans l'agriculture
on trouvera pas 200 ou 500 milles
superman volontaire et donc voilà il ya
pas mal de métier inventé et on en a on
a pensé à quelque chose attention c'est
un peu un roman on s'est dit qu'il ya un
métier qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui et
qui existera demain c'est métier de
manager de ferme
on pense qu'un entrepreneur bien motivé
peut tout à fait créer 5 à 10 microns
ferme comme celle consacrée à la
bourdaisière il mutualiserait ainsi
beaucoup de choses y mutualiserait
l'administratif la commercialisation ils
pourraient mutualiser des outils un
tracteur un broyeur à une unité de
transformation pourquoi pas ce métier on
l'appeler pays culteurs parce qu'on
pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui va cultiver un pays qui va
cultiver quelque chose de très locale
qui va s'impliquer sur son territoire et
ça c'est quelque chose qui manque donc
voila c'était un petit peu le projet
dont je voulais vous parler ce soir et
il me semble que tout le monde on peut
tous participé à cette dynamique
il ya pas mal de gens qui sont en charge
de sens qui se disent que dans leur
travail ils savent pas vraiment à quoi
ils servent à la société et qui
aimeraient peut-être pourquoi pas
habiter à la campagne
eh ben ils peuvent essayer de devenir
pays culteurs maraîcher à temps partiel
pourquoi pas ils peuvent inventer
d'autres métiers dans la distribution
dans la transformation
ce conte pas forcément envie de changer
de métier vous pouvez toujours consommer
local et bio c'est super important on
dit consommer bio ça coûte cher
en fait la chair c'est juste que la
malbouffe est complètement subventionné
vous le savez on l'appelle plusieurs
fois on la paye nos impôts avec la pac
avec les dépenses de santé induites et
puis un autre levier qui est important
c'est financer ce type d'activité parce
que les banques conventionnelles n'aime
pas enfin des banques conventionnelles
m l'agriculture conventionnelle et donc
il ya quelques années mais en découvrant
cela je vais monter une plate forme de
financement participatif qui s'appelle
bluebiz et on permet à des internautes
des citoyens selon les projets soient de
données soit prêté à des projets de ce
type là des projets d'agroécologie et
grâce à ça quand vous prêtez vous pouvez
toucher 2 vous pouvez toucher 2 à 3%
d'intérêt
ces deux fois trois fois livrés c'est
que mieux que le laisser son argent à un
manque et qui va financer de plateformes
offshore en antarctique n'ont donc avec
votre matière grise avec vos bras avec
votre portefeuille avec votre assiette
vous pouvez tous participé à ce
mouvement et pendant ce temps là nous on
va continuer on va continuer
d'expérimenter de créer des projets de
développer des emplois et de faire du
leveling faire du lobbying auprès des
politiques pour qu'ils accompagnent ce
mouvement avec des politiques
incitatives des aménagements fiscaux
on est peut-être moins forme que les
lobbys on a moins d'éléments de
persuasion que les lobbys alimentaire
mais on est tellement plus nombreux et
le monde
qu'on promeut et tellement plus
désirable non franchement un monde dans
lequel on ré concilierait la nature et
la ville le travail et le plaisir
l'alimentation et la santé
victor hugo a dit il est triste de
songer que la nature parle et club
n'écoute pas mais je vous propose une
fois n'est pas coutume qu'on fasse
mentir monsieur hugo et que tous
ensemble on construise une société de
bon sens un monde résilient et fertile
merci